there's an old expression and a little
town in
delaware called claymontello a little
steel town
and they say we're like poor relatives
we show up more invited and we stay
longer than we should so be careful we
may not go back
president biden may not be joking about
staying overseas given the utter
disaster he's created here at home a
whopping 85 percent of the country says
america is on the wrong track
and that includes 78 percent of
democrats
apparently president biden is irritated
by a lack of party enthusiasm when it
comes to a potential second term for him
the new york times reporting the
president is quote irked by democrats
who won't take yes for an answer on
2024.
the times adding quote the president and
his top aides have been stung by the
questions about his plans irritated at
what they see as a lack of respect from
their party and the press
but despite all the odds kamala harris
is trying to instill confidence in the
sinking ship
joe biden is running for re-election and
i will be his ticket mate
full stop close stop
that's it
and as the democrats panic over their
flailing 2024 prospects the media thinks
hillary clinton will be the one to bail
them out cnn has begun their push for
two-time presidential loser to make
another run at the white house and gail
king is practically begging hillary to
do it there's no scenario in 2024 that
you would even remotely consider
you know i i can't imagine it i really
can't i but what i don't know well but
what i can't imagine is staying as
active and outspoken as i can
she can't imagine it jessie she just
can't the two-time loser wants to go for
it a third time so this operation joe
musco has really picked up after the
bike fiasco
people who are on the fence are now
definitely starting to throw the guy at
a retirement party but you're throwing
someone a retirement party and he
doesn't want to retire it's like joe
we're going to have some balloons what
kind of cake do you want and joe's like
i'm not retiring i don't want cake oh
you're going to have the vanilla you're
going to love it and he's out so it's
more of a media coup than a democratic
party because you look at these
questions dana bash is asking when who's
running gail king is asking stephen
colbert is asking aoc are you doing this
they're doing it right in front of joe's
face because he's bad for business the
ratings are down he's no fun to cover i
mean you used to go and go to martha's
vineyard used to go to hawaii or
mar-a-lago what do you go to delaware
now to cover joe biden no one wants to
do that they loved or west texas
they loved
covering barack obama they loved
covering bill clinton because those were
young charismatic guys that took the
fight to republicans day after day joe
biden doesn't lay any wood on the
republicans he's fighting putin harder
than he's fighting the republican party
and to the media republicans are the
enemy and they need to be attacked 24 7.
the media cannot stomach putting out
poll after poll that shows their guy who
they dragged over the finish line at 38
percent you can see them getting
physically ill on the air and talk about
the parent companies at t comcast
they're looking at the market every
single day they've lost what 20 percent
their stock prices are down and now the
donors aren't happy either so this
thing's almost done
now the media has basically started the
primary the primaries begun and now the
primary is anybody but bernie sanders
because the media hates bernie sanders
and half the democratic party hates them
so they're road testing aoc and mayor
pete and kamala but everybody knows it's
going to be a flop so the only shot they
have is to indict donald trump
all right brian i want you to take a
listen to this sound of uh stephen
colbert sucking up to aoc
i know somebody who's going to turn 35
uh about a month before the election in
2024
and uh they represent new york's 14th uh
is is that job appealing to you at all
um i think that theoretically uh listen
i think that we need to focus on keeping
a democracy so it's possible so it's
possible i don't know about it
go ahead brian really uh i mean to me
she's the king she's the queen of queens
uh that's about it that's it in her
district and to resonate uh nationally
is is a bridge too far and i would add
this the worst thing president biden did
is have ron claim or was on volition
give so much credit to the squad because
he cares more about what the squad
thinks than anything else so whatever
his instincts are it's been swapped by
what the squad thinks so he'll never be
in the middle and what the squad thinks
is is really answering to a small swath
of america should have no shot in the
general what i think is interesting is
from david axelrod to james clyburn
they're already talking about in theory
what if joe doesn't run again
it doesn't matter his age doesn't matter
falling off a bike if his results were
better if the economy was humming if
babies could actually uh eat have
formula three times a day if we didn't
leave afghanistan the way we did if he
wasn't over uh in the g7 reacting
instead of leading uh the way we're
seeing right now i don't think the age
the gray hair the moving slow the gate
would even matter and i look back i'm
just writing this down now so ronald
reagan's up in age younger than joe
biden but the people around him were so
good jim baker don't have to worry about
it you know he's got the thing under
control the secretary of state is george
schultz donald regan even though he
clashed with the first lady extremely
competent vice president united states
stewart subway george h.w bush 41 he put
credible people around him and even
though that ronald reagan maybe uh was
in uh slowing down a little let
historians decide the people around him
were so strong the people around this
president are not strong gavin newsom
taking out ads in florida is noteworthy
gavin newsom hopping on truth social is
noteworthy i think governor pritzker
doing everything to look dominant in
illinois is noteworthy and the problem
is that
joe biden
if he won't step aside jesse i think we
start to see more and more hunter
stories hunter stories get some teeth
they get some traction they end up in
the new york times the washington post
where the truth not fabricated like the
russian situation the truth will make it
too hard for him to run again in fact
i'm doing another uh hunter biden uh the
story for fox nation yes
harold what i'd like to ask you is so
you've got this president who's pretty
much the whole country agrees he's a
nightmare
or that the country's headed in the
wrong direction and his job is to to
right that direction right the course i
mean what do you do do you just tell him
not to run i mean who breaks the news to
him
so they have to hope for first of all
it's good to be with you again
they have to hope to be able to say what
james carville said in 96 when clinton
ran for reelection when he asked the
country what do you not like the peace
or the prosperity right now they don't
have that carvill came up with the best
line in the first race which was it's
the economy stupid
this president they need to focus on
something in the middle there if i were
them i think there's some some comments
to be made around the table that i
largely agree with some i don't i don't
necessarily think the whole country
dislikes him i think that there's a big
part of the country there's no doubt
democrat and republican like we saw a
poll where overwhelmed
eight out of ten think we're on the
wrong track it's a minimum of eight i
said you're right in that regard judge
if i were them every monday and two that
i have the president
in a city where some great crime
initiative is happening where some great
education initiative is happening and
talk about ways in which we're going to
not only flood the zone there but help
help amplify this too i'd build a wall
and make it clear we have to if we're
going to have a serious border policy
and as a president who goes down to the
border let that be the takeaway from his
visit there three reverse the keystone
pipeline
uh and make it clear look we're at a
we're at a moment we're at a crisis we
can still pursue a green energy platform
but we have to be cognizant and
realistic about where the country is and
the prices that people are paying for
the things they need most clinton lost
the midterms in 94. i'm not saying
democrats will but guess what he won
re-election in 96. right stop talking
about what people are saying and
complaining about what people are saying
about your first two years and start
doing mental acuity physical acuity
irrelevant if you have policy acuity
that's what i would be focused on if i
were invited i agree with you
but you know what you said it better
than i did but dana the truth is that it
doesn't seem the man has the initiative
to to engage in any of these policy
discussions i mean already who's got
numbers lower than his lower than
kamalas so
what are the what is he can do all the
things harold's talking about but is it
going to matter
congress and the supreme court have
lower and the media have lower poll
numbers than the president um harold
what you're describing is something like
the revenge of the body snatchers none
of that is going to happen i mean what
you're just describing is something that
you what you would do and maybe you will
be running in 20 that would be great
what happened are you running in 2024
yes
no no okay okay so you're saying there's
a chance
okay i've always thought that he would
use president biden would use the post
midterm press conference to announce
he's not running again and i put we have
it in the notes that i said it'll be
like between the monday and the
wednesday after thanksgiving time to
reflect on things talk to his family and
get there but at this point the
narrative is so loud that he's not
running again he might actually have to
file to run for re-election before the
midterms in order to stop this chatter
or he's going to have to have some big
political win he doesn't have a
political win going and all the vultures
are circling the old vultures hillary
clinton the new vultures aoc the current
vultures kamala harris i just want to
say one thing about that you played that
sound bite of her from cnn the other day
just a couple of hours ago this is the
strangest thing i've ever seen the vice
president wanted to put out a
clarification about those comments that
she made on cnn and that this is the
quote she says she should have said the
president intends to run and if he does
i will be his ticketmate we will run
together what she said of that day was
joe biden is running for re-election and
i will be historically so i'm looking at
this going what is the difference versus
is yeah so i so apparently there must
have been some talk within the white
house over the last few days going how
would we fix this and the only way to
fix it was for her to say what's broken
i don't know i don't i don't know what
it needs to be fixed but my question is
who tells them you can't run
susan rice
she's the obama person all right there's
the knife right in him all right hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else